one thing that I that I really I'm very
passionate about like in our business uh
we're in the suit selling business but
really we recruit and hire young men uh
and and my pitch is very simple I hire
young men and teach them how to make a
million dollars a year that's what I do
in my business right our company you
know offices 27 countries across the
world most of the guys that work with us
are in their early to mid 20s when they
start we teach them how to build value
and I tell the guys this I'm like don't
get married in your 20s they go what I'm
like you're going to be working 80 hours
a week with us just commit to that work
80 hours a week and when you're not
working go to the gym why because by the
time you get to 27 28 30 you're going to
have a lot of money and a lot of muscles
and then you can live the life that you
want and that's what I teach the